you have jumped into the world of
cryptocurrency and you talk about it
i don't understand it and i know people
say i don't understand it
i honestly don't understand it i've
asked my son who's very bright at this
stuff to explain it to me
and he says i don't he doesn't want to
try because he knows i will not
understand
so i don't know what it's all about but
i know that you've really gotten into it
so yes in quarantine some people took up
baking and knitting and i deep dived
into crypto and nfts
and i'll tell you why like all jokes
aside is because it made me nervous
and i felt like it was a very masculine
um
area like everybody that i knew that
knew anything about it at the time was
always a man and i was like
it's gonna be that hard and um and
you know it was the pandemic and so i
just deep dived into it and surrounded
myself with
two incredibly smart women that know
everything about it that you know
started libra for
facebook and whatnot and educated myself
on
on crypto on the ethos of crypto on what
crypto is
in the world of the you know
decentralized marketplace like
everything that it stands for
and um and found it to be really
empowering
and then i was like well this is fun
what next
and then i decided to deep dive into
nfts and so through the pandemic
created a a a piece of
a form of entertainment called stoner
cats that we're releasing
in a couple weeks that is an nft and you
can
buy such stoner cats and then that is
your token
to then watch a five-minute long piece
of entertainment it actually sounds like
it sounds like a cool idea and i know
you've had experience in animation and
comedy so
we have uh i think we have a picture
here of the stoner cats
this is yep and uh it's really cool guys
because
they're very guys yeah so here's the
thing
i was gonna say cats just sit around
anyway
well guess what happens when they get
started um
the the so this was all done by really
brilliant people
in at home after work so the animator
the writer the director all did toy
story twos and
spiderverse and space jam and all these
incredible
movies and uh the people that we got to
do the voices everybody just did it
because they thought that it was
different and fun and we all wanted to
do it for the right reasons and it
brings ownership
of content back to the artist and cuts
out the middleman
and so if people like the nfts and they
buy it as tokens then more shows will be
made
we have a picture too of your character
peepee
yep yeah she's real cute guys
look at those eyes